[Aplausos]
há alguns anos atrás quando estava
atuária na reta final do meu curso em
ciências da comunicação seria fazer uma
peritagem que viva comunidade urbana
para 800 motores na cidade onde estudou
e foi o piá basicamente descobrir que
para além de ter sido um dos maiores
desafios da minha vida desta reportagem
às pessoas com mobilidade reduzida
também é um desafio a conseguir circular
nesta cidade é uma das pessoas que
entrevistei apps na fotografia gustavo
cipriano que agora é um amigo e eu
basicamente ou na altura o meu professor
de uma indicação na altura eu achava que
ia eu tenho os cursos inclusive agora à
distância o que poderia ter feito era
legendária arbitragem toda e torná la
acessível às pessoas com deficiência
estamos a falar de cerca de 20 pessoas
com alguma perda auditiva
na altura o que as pessoas não conseguia
perceber que ela andava porque usava com
elas e não conseguia perceber como é que
2 milhões de pessoas segundo o censo de
basicamente eu tinha uma visão sobre a
que o
a ciência do brescia a ian mas não
precisa nada sou o acusado de ser mas
não percebi nada sobraria deficiência e
achava concluiu a maioria das pessoas
não conheciam este mundo e perante isto
[Música]
quando a mariana andava em 2012
andava a preparar o edital publicado a
temática da deficiência ea idéia era
precisamente por um lado as novidades
que existem na área as pessoas com
deficiência e por outro eu não tenho
qualquer tipo de incapacidade não
estavam com ela descobrir que transforma
vidas das pessoas
uma pessoa com deficiência auditiva
profunda paulo houve descobri também que
existe a possibilidade das pessoas com
deficiência auditiva serem atendidos
através de vídeo conferência e serviços
alguma forma ser mais inclusivo
na parte musical com aquela que nós
acabamos de ouvir as pessoas com
deficiência auditiva não devem ser
mudadas a possibilidade de ouvir música
sentir movida e também descobrir que há
um aparelho
neste caso para pessoas com grandes
limitações motoras que através de um
simples clique do nariz está a cabeça do
pai com dedo podem ativar prosseguir um
trecho musical elas conseguirem fazer
parte de uma grande orquestra em filmes
como a final com o ator
ian e também teve que tirar dinheiro
teatro com a descrição de passar a
língua gestual e vários atos com sua
consciência
também hoje em dia todas a cadeira de
rodas para observar o edson
sei que a audiolivros livros em braile
ou núcleos rurais
as exposições podem ser tata steel
grafias podem ser tratadas as culturas e
as pinturas podem afetar as pessoas com
deficiência visual
também há projetos fotográficos em que
são apresentadas sem corresponderem aos
padrões de beleza que a maioria das
pessoas tem atuais mas que no entanto
acho que conseguem mostrar como sendo a
apresentar-se numa bonita ea outros
projetos em que eu certamente não teria
nada mas eu não fiquei porque não
conseguia falar e eu usava um simples
para comunicar mas há atualmente cada
vez mais meios tecnológicos que maneira
for necessário dar condições às pessoas
para fazer porque tornar um mundo
inclusivo e temos físicos e comunicação
tem que ser uma coisa que não está
ligado à folha artificial é um direito
social e ao fazê lo está a fazer isto
por um nicho
estamos a fazer
nós todos em portugal assinou uma
convenção em 2009 para as pessoas com
deficiência em que tinha terminado os
princípios que seu propósito e assumiu o
compromisso de transformar a realidade
portuguesa e aplaudi lá são em nós em
termos de legislação sobre os dispêndios
mais avançado em legislação para estas
pessoas
no entanto na hora de pôr as coisas
todas em prática
a susepe albufeira tão gostoso quem
calcula as mentalidades
mas o caminhante tanto eu como a mariana
descobrimos que o pior problema para
estas pessoas não são as rampas mal
feitas nas escadas o paralelo
basicamente as atitudes das pessoas e
descobrir isto é perceber que a
sociedade em geral que a intenção de
incriminá porque está mal informado
o trabalho em conjunto para conseguir
cada vez mais inclusiva
imagine um mundo pelas vossas caras mas
imagine um mundo onde a única forma de
comunicar um cheiro foi morar longe
crime
os técnicos tinham muito deste ano
não é o que vai acontecer mas é pra
vocês pensaram que ele nichos durante a
nossa apresentação de seu na índia uma
das melhores e piores experiências que
já tive
eu sou terapeuta da fala e durante dez
anos trabalha com crianças com
necessidades educativas especiais e
desde há seis anos envolver muito na
área de inovação e empreendedorismo
social como estava a morar em coimbra em
2011 e voltar à universidade será
exatamente na história nem vai
empreendedorismo e um dia fui ao
refeitório na universidade de coimbra e
vi um póster dizer uma coisa semelhante
como este verão vai fazendo coisas
diferentes que disse eu quero aquilo que
escrevi e quando dei por mim estava na
índia sozinha uma aldeia tribal porque
achei que uma experiência ainda deveria
ter procedido mesma aldeia tribal e aí
porém com as minhas próprias
incapacidades
eu sou terapeuta da fala comunicar
não é um problema mas foi por um sítio
pouca gente falava inglês
toda a gente falava ing e para mim foi
um problema seja compreende claramente
que eu já tinha estudado mexer no
primeiro papel na minha pele tem
capacidade depende do contexto eu posso
ter uma incapacidade não é só para
pessoas com deficiência
eu sinto me com capacidade muito grande
na índia mas o que é exatamente
comunicar não vou entrar em um processo
lógico de neurociências
nós precisamos de três coisas no emissor
de um setor e de uma mensagem não é e
vamos defender que não há problemas na
emissão no setor né não há barreiras à
comunicação aqui e percebi também que
como terapeuta da fala
eu estava a capacitar as crianças pra
contexto muito específico eu trabalhava
com elas na escola estava uma vez por
semana com elas e ir embora e que
funcionava além
mas com o tempo comecei a perceber que
não era nem bom pra mim nem bom para as
crianças nem pras famílias porque essas
crianças crescem estas famílias precisam
desde a rua precisam de um restaurante
não é preciso ter um sistema de casa e
comecei a perceber que por mais
competências que a estas pessoas
enfim não era suficiente não era este o
impacto que a prioridade em áreas que
elas necessitavam quando and feio meu
clube que tipo de emprego estável tinha
minha mãe deixou as mãos à cabeça e teve
que fazer não é nesta estudar e conhecer
um projeto que é o projeto tem mais
chances na minha pele
foi isso que eu sempre porque achei que
todos nós devemos sentir na pele o que é
a incapacidade seja numa viagem seja por
conhecer alguém que tem capacidade todos
nós vamos passar por isso inicia este
projecto com alguns amigos e trabalhamos
exatamente na comunicação porque comecei
muito bem segundo a convenção de
comunicação via está a informação é um
direito com toda a gente
o que nós fazemos para que isso aconteça
eu não podia ao longo destes dois anos
estava no projeto falar só do coração eu
tenho que começar a estudar em termos
econômicos de que forma poderia criar um
impacto
então vamos entrar pelos centros com seu
estúdio você falar com empresários e
precisamos exatamente isto contribui
todo fala estava a trabalhar para estes
8% que é mais ou menos o número de
pessoas que têm alguma deficiência em
portugal e incapacidade grave não é um
tempo que eu gosto de treinar mas é o
termo utilizado por celso ferro voltou a
usar agora 20% têm capacidade legendas
ea 72% de alguma forma não está ligado a
este mundo mas depois comecei a perceber
neste 32% temos famílias ou temos amigos
o temos alguém que de uma forma ou outra
poderá ter uma capacidade no futuro nós
vamos vencer o al vai mas os avc só
então percebi que eu queria trabalhar
com estes vendedores por cento
era esta população que nós precisávamos
de capacitar para é colher melhor para
informar a gestante não o contrário não
informar as pessoas com incapacidade
para se adaptarem ao outro lado mas sim
a sociedade em si e são exemplos do que
nós consideramos uma comunicação mais ou
menos acessível comunicação inclusive
haveria que era uma comunicação mais
para nichos seja o brasil língua gestual
que é útil mas que não serve também toda
a gente eu também não sei brasil de
comunicação possível de certa forma é
pra todos esses são alguns exemplos que
teria como boas práticas não são
perfeitas mas são boas práticas por
exemplo a linha do metro o fato ter
curso agora também com a simbologia para
daltónicos tem uma simbologia associada
àquela linha e é de fácil entendimento
entre as duas chefes não sei se toda a
gente já foi um hospital é super caótico
mas os hospitais necessitaram de ser uma
forma de organização interna de 10 a
noção do que é prioritário que é que
deveria primar ser atendido foi criada a
triagem de manchester para a organização
dos serviços mas os próprios utentes
também conseguem perceber mais ou menos
quanto tempo vão ficar à espera nos
serviços mais ou menos porque nós já
sabemos que vamos lá temos uma pulseira
verde mg que ela não vai resolver mexer
isso é uma boa prática na austrália
deus tem estes quadros com quadros de
comunicação servem para pessoas que têm
alguma incapacidade nível da comunicação
mas que conseguem usar símbolos jean mas
também serve pra mim sou estrangeiro não
fala inglês
eu consigo me comunicar com o taxista
porque estão formados para tal
para conseguir um varão se fica no sítio
este é um exemplo que eu acho fantástico
imaginem voltando a primeira flights
fosse tudo por escrito o impacto que
teria um impacto sem esta imagem
esta imagem dos portugueses no facebook
isto foi viral é um é uma sinalética na
holanda e conseguem perceber exatamente
o que acontece se vocês fizerem as
nossas gentes cidade na rua e foi parar
ao youtube é falado nem sempre se
entende seja não é só com a fala não é
só isto que nós fazemos que é o tio
também podemos usar a escrita é única
face ao todo comportamento verbal
cultural
temos a simbologia temos no brasil temos
a língua gestual e uma das frases que
tanto eu ia fia concordamos
quando o mc estávamos a preparar a
apresentação foi uma moça do mandela e
zie carné
mas poderosa do mundo é a comunicação
entre as pessoas por isso deixamos aqui
o desafio que é de que forma é que a
partir de hoje vocês vão usar essa arma
para mudar o mundo então ela
[Aplausos]